in this video i'm going to show you
exactly how you can replicate the top
gun maverick aircraft carrier from the
movie in twin motion 100
free okay so today i'm going to show you
exactly how we can recreate this top gun
aircraft carrier basically we're going
to be using twin motion and a series of
free objects downloaded off the internet
to be able to replicate exactly what you
see here before you today
now it may seem extremely complicated on
the get-go but i guarantee you it is
extremely easy now so i can show you
exactly what i did here we're going to
go by file new scene and completely
start again no i do not want to save
anything that i've created in twin
motion which is a shame but that's okay
so what we're going to start by doing is
going down settings in the bottom
left-hand corner coming across the
location going to background and getting
rid of our background entirely we don't
need a background because we are in the
middle of the ocean now if we come back
to settings go to weather effects and
turn our ocean on we'll start to see
quickly how we create this scene i do
want to change this from a clear river
to the atlantic ocean so it's nice deep
dark blue and if we just pan around we
see
incredible endless nothingness just
water next we're going to introduce our
sky dome so if we come in all the way
across go to our skydome object i'm
going to pick a morning afternoon cloudy
just a random sky you can select
whichever one you think is right for you
i'm going to put in m o a f cloudy 32
drag drop and let twin motion basically
put that into the scene so as you can
see that entire scene has very quickly
changed to something a little bit more
photorealistic so all these objects are
basically found on sketchfab.com i'll
leave a link down in the description to
them all below but if you simply type in
aircraft carrier you'll see a number of
free and paid for resources that you can
use to basically replicate what i'm
showing you here today that's the one i
used again it is in the description down
below
so now if we come back to twin motion
and we import a brand new object let's
go open
carrier and use that gerald fbx i'm
going to keep the hierarchy i'm going to
fix the uv and textures up axes auto and
conversion units auto and then i'm going
to import that carrier
so if i fly around a little bit we're
going to see
a very big plain white box dropped in
too low into our scene so what i'm going
to do is slowly just drag that up out of
the water so it sits where it needs to
and then i'm going to click on my little
material selector tool click on the boat
come down to color more empty texture
open
and i'm going to find the main material
of that boat so i think for twin motion
the main material is the diffuse so if i
open that up it'll automatically put
that texture onto our boat and we're
basically ready to go now if we want to
go into a bit more detail we can
continue with gaunting into the settings
opening up the metallicness turning that
on and then replacing that with our
metallic texture opening that and also
changing our bump across
to the normal so we get a bit more
texture and that's how quickly and
easily we can introduce our aircraft
carrier into twin motion we're going to
repeat those same steps for the aircraft
so open back into my downloads let's
find
this f14 which was referenced in the
movie and repeat those same steps and
there we go now we've introduced our f14
directly in to this space what you'll
see is a lot of the objects and
materials seem like they're missing so
we want to again click on that material
go into settings and turn two-sided on
so we see everything from both sides all
the time but now we have our f14 i'm
going to repeat those same steps for the
other airplanes that i downloaded which
includes the f-18 f-35 and just a random
jet fighter as well and there we go now
we've imported three of our jets into
this aircraft carrier and lined them up
all we want to do now is basically go
around spread them anywhere we want on
this aircraft carrier to be able to
create the scene that we're looking for
with these catapults that we see here on
the aircraft carrier you also see the
flaps that we saw in the movie that come
up so we can type minus 45 to basically
deflect any of that jet engine
propulsion and protect anybody behind
this scene so if we were trying to
create a photorealistic scene we'd
definitely be introducing these at a 45
or even 90 degree angle to protect our
people below generally speaking i know
very little about the army the navy or
any military items but what i do know is
they look like catapult launch pads as
do they and that looks like a landing
strip so we can basically create our
scene based around those elements there
and if we click on these sections here
that are outlined they come up in our
finder
as elevators so if we wanted to drag
this down all the way
we could basically introduce an elevator
pit duplicate our plane across have two
planes
and dive into our elevator pit that
basically looks identical to what we saw
in the film itself if you want you can
even come back into the vehicles and the
aircrafts in twin motion introduce some
helicopters and basically plant them
wherever you see fit so if i wanted
three helicopters here for example i
could just replicate them over and over
again until i had plenty of helicopters
perfectly aligned on my aircraft carrier
and that's all from me today i'll see
you next monday